[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Standing next
to me is Winifred Reilly.
She is a psychotherapist
specializing in marital therapy
and relationship issues in a
private practice in Berkeley,
California.
In her 35 years of
clinical practice,
she has treated
hundreds of couples,
many who are convinced
they're headed for divorce.
Ms. Reilly has been a
guest lecturer on marriage
and sexuality, and
her writing has
appeared on the "Huffington
Post", "The Good Men
Project", "XO Jane," and her
blog, "Speak of Marriage".
I'm so excited that we get
to hear Winifred Reilly.
Thanks.
WINIFRED REILLY:
Thank you so much.
So I'm going to
start first-- thank
you so much for having me.
I'm going to start
first by telling you
this personal story.
So my husband and I were married
early on a Sunday morning.
By late that afternoon, we were
in the car driving down 101
to spend a few days
down in Big Sur.
So our friends had
painted Just Married
across the back of our car.
So as we're driving
along, people
are honking, and waving,
and giving the thumbs up.
And then this guy
in a pick up truck
comes pulling on up to our car.
And he's honking for my husband
to roll down the window.
And then at about
75 miles an hour,
this guy leans across
the cab of his truck
and yells out the
window, don't do it.
So I'm married, what?
Maybe five hours, six hours.
And I'm thinking, nah.
That'll never be us.
Not the business of yelling out
of the car window at newlyweds,
but the idea that we would
be disgruntled or unhappy.
It never occurred to me.
Now, you'd think that I
would have known better given
my work, given that I'm a
marriage and family therapist.
I mean, you'd think I would
have been better prepared
in some way for what
marriage would be.
But actually, I was just
as naive and unprepared
as my clients.
I had ideas that
were fairly useless,
like we have so much in
common and we're so in love.
How hard could this be?
So here's what a
client of mine said
on the eve of her
third anniversary.
Yeah.
I know marriage takes work.
Everybody knows that.
I was prepared for that, and I
knew we have our difficulties.
But I never, ever imagined
that the biggest difficulty
in my life would be
my husband, George.
So I'm here today to talk
about my book, "It Takes One
to Tango".
I'm going to talk about
why marriage is hard,
and I'm going to
tell you a little bit
of my personal
story, how I changed
my own marriage by
taking a leadership role,
and how you can create a
vibrant and satisfying loving
relationship too.
So the question is, why
is marriage so hard?
Well, here.
Marriage puts two people
into a small space
with the expectation of keeping
them there for a lifetime.
And then says, good luck.
Marriage doesn't come with
a guide book or a road map.
And none of us come in with
all the skills that we need.
Many of us have had
terrible role models.
We've had parents who fought to
the death or hated each other
and finally divorced.
Or we had over-idealized
romantic role models,
like grandparents who
were married 75 years
and swore they'd never
had one, single argument.
Now, and then there you
are on your honeymoon
on the third day, and you're
ready to kill each other.
So you've completely blown
it right out of the gate.
Then we also have
mistaken ideas,
like marriage shouldn't be
hard, or people who fight
should get a divorce.
Or those people look really
happy, what's wrong with us?
You know, so we have the
negative role models.
There's a confusion
about the difference
between marriage and courtship.
Courtship is that wonderful
drunk on love beginning
phase where it's all about
sameness and loveliness.
And you just can't
believe that you finally
found someone so perfect,
someone so much like you
with so much in common.
And unfortunately,
courtship doesn't last.
And many people really do think
that's what relationships are.
So when courtship ends, they
just move on to the next one.
Or when marriage gets difficult
or the long the longer
relationships start to
struggle, people think, nah.
I'd better move on.
So when people struggle and they
find marriage to be difficult,
what I want people to know
is that nothing is wrong.
It's just that marriage
is a really tough teacher
and we all have plenty to learn.
But many of us don't like
the idea of being beginners.
We think, somehow,
we're supposed
to be good at everything, even
without any practice at all.
Now, my graduate school training
mimicked some of these myths
about marriage that were
not particularly helpful.
But worse, it seemed
to make the trouble
that people had in
marriage be more
of a pathology, sort of an
aberration, more than the norm.
But I was thinking, there
are some really lovely people
that I see in my practice.
And my husband and I,
were not actually crazy,
but we were going at it in
ways that didn't make sense.
So I thought, something
is wrong with this idea.
So I decided to figure out why.
And in order to do that,
I decided to turn myself
into a marriage expert.
Now, back then, none
of this existed.
I couldn't just
sit at my computer.
Well, actually, I didn't even
have a computer back then.
And I couldn't just
sit down and Google
why is my husband
driving me crazy?
What am I supposed to do?
There was none of that.
So I went to the bookstore.
You know, I read books, and I
took workshops and trainings,
and went to conferences.
And here's the most
interesting thing that I found.
It pretty much turned everything
I understood about marriage
and relationships upside down.
So most of us
think that marriage
is about agreement
and consensus,
about compromising,
and meeting halfway.
It's our need for consensus
that's driving us crazy.
We need this agreement,
we need this validation.
We need somebody to say, yes.
I hear you.
I agree with you.
I perfectly understand you.
Oh, yes.
What you're saying makes
perfect sense, and yes.
Let's do it your way.
But, of course, you know, of
course we'd all like that.
I mean, everybody
wants validation.
You know what I like to
say is that validation
is a perfectly
fine thing to want
and it's a really
dangerous thing to need.
So here's essentially
what it comes down to.
We need to learn how
to disagree, not agree.
Now, I'm not saying that we
have to fight all the time
and that that's the
key to happiness.
I'm just saying that
what we have to do
is we need to learn to
effectively deal with being
two different people.
This was 180 degrees
off of everything
that I believed up until
then, but somehow it
made perfect sense to me.
I didn't know how to
apply it to my life,
but I knew that I
was onto something.
So let's consider this
quote from Einstein.
"Central to the advancement
of human civilization
is the spirit of open inquiry.
We must not only learned to
tolerate our differences--
we must welcome them as the
richness and diversity which
can lead to true intelligence."
So I read this quote, and I'm
in a workshop for therapists.
And we're working with
how to deal with our most
impossible, difficult couples.
So I thought immediately
of this couple
I'll call Bruce and Cindy.
They were my couple from hell.
They fought about everything.
They'd get to the corner
and they couldn't decide--
you know, if they're just
taking a walk-- whether they
should go right or left.
So I tried to imagine
die-hard vegan Bruce welcoming
as rich and diverse his
wife Cindy's interest
in eating hamburger, when
this guy would not even
wear leather shoes.
And what I realized
is that's the point.
We don't have to get--
Bruce and Cindy are never
going to agree on anything.
And the good news is,
we didn't actually
have to make them agree.
But here's one of the pieces
of trouble with consensus.
OK.
So have you ever noticed that
your version and your spouse's
version sound nothing alike?
Have you ever thought
that maybe you're
living in alternate
realities, parallel realities
on a good day?
So here's how I observed
this in my office.
Somebody is there and
they're starting to talk.
And they say, you know,
and this thing happened,
and that thing happened.
And then their partner moves
like, some micro-movement,
a little eyebrow, a little--
[SNIFFING]
Something happens.
And, what?
What?
And they're completely riveted.
They can't finish a sentence.
They can't complete a thought.
And they say, see?
This is what I mean.
We can't talk about X. I'm
not allowed to bring up Y.
And I say, why not?
Who made these rules?
And so if you want to
know who made these rules,
I'm going to ask you
to take a minute,
and I want you to think
about, imagine and remember,
the two of you back in the
early days of your relationship.
There you are.
You're in Starbucks
sharing cafe lattes.
Maybe you're actually drinking
one tea with two straws.
And you're planning your
weekend away, romantic.
The first trip to the country.
And now meanwhile, in
some smoky back room,
your people and your
partner's people
are back there negotiating the
terms of your relationship.
OK.
Fine.
I won't question
how many times a day
she has to talk to her mother.
OK.
Fine.
And she's just not
going to bring up
what the cost of
those club-level seats
are at the ball park.
And all right, really?
OK.
They'll never, ever,
ever talk about sex.
So this gets signed into law.
They shake hands, Meanwhile,
you're out there having a lark.
You have no idea that these
are actually the rules that
will confine you.
They will define you.
They will make you miserable.
They will make you feel like
you are living in a box,
until you have the strength
and stamina to change them.
Now, [INAUDIBLE]
about courtship, about
courtship being about all
things lovely and wonderful.
These rules, you made these
rules back in the beginning
when the goal was to keep
the peace, to fall in love,
to preserve your bond, to
keep your partner essentially
from thinking you're
completely awful
and deciding to leave you.
So all of these
things are hidden,
but you make these rules and
you will have to live with them.
So that's what courtship is.
And so here is marriage.
Marriage is essentially about
the rest of your life together.
You can't keep up the
facade of not being yourself
when you're in a
long relationship.
So marriage is really about
coming to terms with the fact
that you are two different
people, that you want
different things, that
you like different things,
that some of the things
you're going to want
are going to clash with what
your partner has in mind.
Now, this is really,
really important.
We have to figure out
how to deal with this,
our differences, with grace.
And in order to do
this, you're going
to have to learn how
to stand on your own.
This is crucial.
This is the whole
point that I wrote--
this is why I wrote this book.
If you can't stand on your own,
if you can't take a position,
you're never going to
challenge the rules.
You're not going
to like your life.
You're not going to
like your partner.
like how you feel.
You will have compromised
your core values.
You will have sunk below
your own bottom line.
You will be fearful.
You will find yourself spending
years saying things like,
we're not allowed to do this,
and I'm not allowed to do that.
You're going to feel trapped.
You are going to
blame your spouse.
If you imagine yourself one
year, five year, 10 years.
I'm married almost 40 years.
Find yourself all the
way down the line,
you won't even be able
to recognize yourself.
You will have turned
yourself into a pretzel
of acceptability, and you
won't be able to stand it.
Why this is important
is that you have
to realize what's at stake.
You've sacrificed
your I for your we.
And in order to be
happily married,
to be in a satisfying
relationship,
we have to be as
connected to ourselves
as we are to our spouse.
If you can't do
that, what's at stake
is your vitality,
your well-being,
and really even possibly
your entire relationship.
So here's where my
personal story comes in.
I come home from this workshop.
I've gotten this new
idea, and I'm ecstatic.
I've finally figured out why
my husband and I are fighting
like a couple of junkyard dogs.
I figure, this is it.
I've got it.
So I come home, and
I'm all excited.
And I say, essentially,
honey, this
is the greatest thing
that's ever happened.
I'm going to dismantle
our entire marriage right
down to the rafters
and we're going
to remodel this whole
thing while we live in it,
and I'm going to be the
architect and the carpenter.
So my husband, you
know, he didn't
embrace all of these ideas with
quite the relish that I did.
And you know, pretty
much what he said was,
I pretty much think our
marriage is fine as it is.
So that didn't deter me.
I decided, no.
I'm going to keep at it.
I knew that this was right.
You know, but then
actually-- so to be honest,
what he actually said after
I think our marriage is fine
as it is, he actually said,
you went to a workshop
for the weekend and you
came back brainwashed.
And you are, essentially, you're
not going to save our marriage.
You are about to destroy it.
So, I mean, I can't blame
him for thinking this.
I mean, I'm saying things
like, in order to be close,
we have to be separate.
In order to stop fighting,
we have to disagree.
You know, these things
don't make any sense,
and so I can understand.
And here's the other thing.
I was pretty much--
here's the picture.
This is exactly what I was like.
I came home like
a lunatic zealot.
[LAUGHTER]
I knew that this
was right, but there
was some way in which I couldn't
actually sell it to him.
So I kept trotting out my
good ideas, and books to read,
and things to do.
And you know, I was like
a door-to-door salesman
trying to sell a reluctant
housewife a new vacuum cleaner.
I don't really need this.
Mine works just fine.
So I was about to
give up, and then I
realized that maybe I'm
going about this all wrong.
I realized that
the instructions,
what I was going by, was that
you have to stand on your own.
You have to take risks.
But what I was doing
was exactly the opposite
of what I needed to do.
I was trying to get
my husband's buy in.
It was as if I
was saying, honey,
I could very well stand
and be separate from you
if you don't join me.
I can't take the lead
if you don't come along.
And that was when I realized
that this business of changing
my marriage was going
to be a whole lot harder
and a little more complicated
than I had first anticipated.
I realized then that if I was
going to change my marriage,
I was going to have
to change it myself.
So I didn't have any real
rules for how to do this,
but these are the
principles that I had.
You can't change your partner.
You have to take risks.
You have to challenge the
rules that confine you
and frustrate you.
You have to recognize and
accept that this is not
a kind of a beeline to change.
You're going to have to
learn by falling seven times
and standing up eight.
And most of all, you're going
to need to focus on yourself.
Well, I decided that
focusing on myself
was the best place to begin.
So instead of focusing on
all of the ways in which he
was contributing to
our difficulties,
when focusing on myself I
discovered a handful of things.
I'm as stubborn as my husband.
I am as likely to
start a fight as he is.
I am maybe even less
likely to allow it to end.
I will be willing to
fight about anything,
as ridiculous and
stupid as it might be,
as long as I have to
end up being right.
But the worst thing, the most
painful observation that I had
was that I realized
that I have the staying
power of a dandelion.
Under pressure, I
would just crumble.
And it didn't really
match my sense of myself,
who I am out in the world.
But somehow at home,
there were these ways
that our interactions would,
you know, just make me dissolve.
So I decided that further than
just this focus, which helped,
I learned how to stop pulling
my end of the tug-of-war rope.
What I realized
that I needed to do
was I needed to pick this most
frustrating, mind boggling
interaction that I would
have with my husband.
It's what I refer to as
our loopy-logic fight.
We'd start-- it didn't matter
what we were talking about,
but within a short
period of time,
he's throwing things in
from left field and right.
And I'd be saying, wait,
wait, wait a minute.
Weren't we talking about shoes?
Wait a second.
I thought we were
talking about bananas.
What's going on?
And I would just lose
my ability to think.
He was very good.
I really have to--
I admire competence.
He was terrific, but
it would make me lose--
I felt I was losing my mind.
So what I began doing was
experimenting with what would
it take for me to maintain
my thoughts, to feel
like I'm staying in one piece?
So I tried deep breathing, and
I tried counting backwards.
And I tried writing down the
points that I wanted to make.
But none of that worked.
So then one day I decided to
take a physical step back,
and I noticed I was able to
maintain my thinking better,
but not very well.
So I took another step back.
And then I experimented.
I'd come back in the
room, and I would just
lose it in about six seconds.
And I'd come back
out of the room.
So I did this--
honestly, people say,
how long did it take?
It took a year.
It took a year
for me to actually
be able to stand there.
And this is how it happened.
One day in the middle of
one of our stupid go rounds,
I realized I didn't
have to leave the room.
There I was, and it was
like suddenly his words
were like snowflakes
falling through the air.
And I was perfectly calm,
and I knew what I thought,
and I knew what I wanted to say.
And it was like popping
outside of the pull of gravity
and just floating
free through space.
And so here's what I'm
going to ask for you to do.
I would like for you--
here's my question.
What experience
do you have, what
is it like for you, what
experience do you have
where you lose yourself?
Where what you want,
it feels out of reach?
Where what goes on makes your
head spin and frustrate you,
or makes you shut down
or cry, or blow up?
What one situation would
you like to master?
So I'd like you to just take
a minute and write it down.
One way to think
about it is this.
Instead of X, I want to do
Y. Instead of blowing up,
I want to remain calm.
Instead of crying
when I'm angry,
I want to be able to hold
my thoughts together.
I want to be able
to express myself.
Now, in order for
you to do this,
you're going to have
to do two things.
You're going to have to give up
trying to change your partner,
and I mean really give it up.
I don't mean just lip service,
no pun intended there.
I don't mean lip service to the
idea of secretly believing you
partner should change.
People come in and they--
it's like they're bringing
in a broken toaster
to the fix-it shop in my office.
And it's like, here.
I finally brought-- I'm bringing
my situation to an expert.
I've tried to fix my
partner, and here it goes.
And so it's not like that.
The thing about marriage
is that it's a choice.
We can stay with our
partner, or we can leave.
But if we're going to stay,
we have one of two choices.
We can be completely
driven nuts by our partner,
or we can figure out what we're
going to do with ourselves.
So the other thing you're
going to have to do,
you're going to have to totally
give up the "it takes two"
paradigm.
You're going to
have to throw out
all the stuff about fairness
and needing both partners
to work as a team and change.
See, this is one of the
things that surprised me
in my own marriage, that as I
was busy focusing on myself,
my husband was actually
changing in ways all on his own.
He was calming down.
And occasionally, he was even
the more levelheaded arguer.
When we would get
into something, he--
you know, one day he's
completely surprised me.
I came home to make lunch,
and he left all this stuff
all over the counter,
the plate and the fork
and all of that stuff.
And I was immediately incensed.
And so we sort of got into it.
Oh, like, what a nice way for
you to come home and say hello.
Well, you know, I
only have 15 minutes
and I have to deal
with your mess.
Back and forth, and
back and forth we went.
And then he stopped
and he said, OK.
Hold on a minute.
Let's back up.
So in other words, you
come home in a rush
and complain about my mess.
I get defensive, and
you feel despair.
Is that about right?
And I said, uh, yeah.
Now, really, I was
about to fall over.
And he said, yeah.
I can see that.
And then he began to clean up.
So what happens when you
stop focusing on your partner
and you focus on yourself--
that was what he did.
He was focused on me, and then
he was focused on himself.
So you're going to
have to completely
give up the two to tango
paradigm in order for this
to work.
Now, here's the interesting
thing that people say,
you know, in business, people
are impressed with leadership.
They call leaders, they
call it being an innovator.
You know, they say, you
know, you're a trendsetter.
But when I suggest
that people have
to take [INAUDIBLE]
in their own marriage,
they think that I'm
essentially telling them
that they're going to have
to be some sort of doormat.
So I promise you, I'm not asking
you to roll over and play dead,
or give up on the things
that are important to you,
or just live with conditions
that you can't stand.
I'm really suggesting
that you recognize
the power of being a leader for
change in your relationship,
and it really is going to
start with that one thing
that I'm asking you
to look at, the one
thing that you can change, the
one thing that you can control.
And don't be surprised if
it takes a long time for you
to master that that one
thing that I asked you to do.
It's an incredibly--
it's so much more
empowering than waiting
for your partner to change.
So you know, and basically
what I want you to understand
is that you have more
power than you think.
If you're skeptical,
you're not alone.
I mean, really, I'm
asking you to let
go of one of the most cherished
beliefs, that people have
to change as a
team, that it's not
worth doing if your
spouse doesn't join you.
So I'm really just asking
you to take the challenge,
challenge yourself.
The goal is not here to turn
you into a little island
of self-sufficiency.
It's about turning you
into a partner who's
capable of change, who's
capable of leadership.
One person must take the
first step in change.
My invitation to you is, why
not let that person be you?
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: I love
this book so much.
WINIFRED REILLY: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: And one
of the chapters--
in almost every
chapter there was
something where I had to put
it down and think about it.
But almost everything
in Chapter Six,
when it says "what happens
once you calm down?"
WINIFRED REILLY: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: And that, for
me, has been in my marriage,
a very difficult thing to
do, is just to calm down.
Because I--
SPEAKER 1: It's high pressure.
WINIFRED REILLY: Yes.
Under the same
impression or feelings
that you were
talking about, where
we have to do this together.
We have to agree.
And my husband really likes
for me to agree with him.
WINIFRED REILLY: Uh huh.
SPEAKER 1: So it's very--
WINIFRED REILLY:
That's not surprising.
SPEAKER 1: --Causes
tons of issues.
So calming down, it's
just such a great thought
and a great concept.
WINIFRED REILLY: And it's not
something that's easy to do.
You know, I mean, when you're
really upset and somebody
says to you, calm down, I
mean, how useless is that?
SPEAKER 1: Right.
WINIFRED REILLY: You
know, so it actually
has to happen from inside.
And it really is another one of
those kind of try this and try
that, you know?
Like I was saying, in
order to stay present
in my loopy-logic fight,
you know, I tried counting,
I tried digging my
fingernails in my hand.
I tried planting my feet.
You know, it really
just ended up
being that I needed
the physical distance.
And little did I know that
what I was doing at that point
was kind of calming
down my neocortex.
I was staying in that little
sliver of reasonableness
while the kind of flood of
the whole rest of my brain
was taking over and acting like
it was some kind of emergency.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
Yes.
And that, on page 131--
WINIFRED REILLY: Mhm.
SPEAKER 1: You talk about how--
and this is, for me, a
revolutionary thought--
"for most people,
it takes some time
to grow comfortable
with the idea of being
responsible for
comforting ourselves
when we're disappointed or
hurt and somewhat longer
to discover its benefits."
And you'd recognized the
point of self-soothing
with your children.
WINIFRED REILLY: Yes, and
we all-- you know, yeah.
We want them to
self-soothe so that we
can get a night's sleep.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
WINIFRED REILLY: Right?
SPEAKER 1: And to
self-soothe ourselves,
as a partner in the marriage.
WINIFRED REILLY: Yeah.
I mean, if you think
about it, you're
in the middle of a
thing with your partner.
If you're relying on
them to be soothing you,
I mean, they're busy.
Their brain is lit
up at that moment.
So what are you going to do?
Go into some sort of free fall?
I mean, you have to actually
settle down and tell yourself,
I'm really going to be OK.
But one of my clients
had a wonderful phrase.
He said that the thing that
would help him the most
was that when he got anxious
he would remind himself,
he would say, OK.
I might get hurt here,
but I'm not going to die.
[LAUGHTER]
That was his self-soothing,
and so we find something.
SPEAKER 1: What are some
of your suggestions?
WINIFRED REILLY: OK.
Well, like I said,
you can breath.
I think you have to
start with the novel idea
that it's actually your job.
And I think that's a
big beginning part.
You know, being able to lean on
each other and being together,
like I said, this is not
about being a little island.
It's just about-- it's nice to
be able to lean on each other,
but you have to be able
to stand on your feet,
especially when
you're not agreeing.
You know, you can't
lean on somebody else
while they're agitated or
holding their position.
So you can breathe.
You can talk yourself down.
You can take breaks.
You can say, hold on.
I'm just getting flooded.
I'm going to step out.
I'm not suggesting that you, you
know, come back two days later.
I'm saying, just five minutes.
Quiet your brain down.
So it really is an experiment.
Sometimes there
are issues that are
so hot to deal with that
you pick them up tomorrow.
SPEAKER 1: Mhm.
That's great.
Did you want to ask a question?
And have Dory's
questions right here.
WINIFRED REILLY: OK.
SPEAKER 1: I'm going to
read the Dory questions,
and feel free to add as
many as you would like.
And it is anonymous.
So the first
question we have is,
how to convince your partner
to go to couples therapy,
and is it helpful
to do it alone?
WINIFRED REILLY: Great.
I love that question.
You can't convince
or persuade someone
to do something that
they're uncomfortable with.
You can ask, and it's
actually your job to ask.
I mean, nobody is going to
advocate for you except you.
But you know, there are
reasons people don't
want to go to couple's therapy.
They think it's a first
step toward divorce.
They're fearful.
They think that things
are fine as they are.
Let's, you know,
don't rock the boat.
Or, you know, they just
don't believe in it.
And so it's "The One
to Tango" principle.
If there's something important
to you, go on your own.
Take the lead.
I do work with some
people by themselves
without their partner, and
so a good couples therapist
will actually help you,
not just take your side.
That's not that helpful.
I mean, it's lovely,
but if you're
talking about nonsense
in your relationship,
you actually have to have
somebody who can, you know,
not just commiserate with
you, but actually help
you take charge of yourself.
So you know, I think
sometimes what people--
it sort of seems obvious.
You can start by saying, this
is really important to me
and I'd like you to go.
At least try it once.
But really, go by yourself.
Go by yourself.
A lot can happen, if you don't
just go there to complain,
but you go there to say--
like I did-- you
know, say, oh, wait.
I'm as big of a hothead.
Oh, here's my contribution
to the difficulty,
and I want help with that.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
What are some of
the steps one can
take when they're screaming,
name calling, as well
as verbal abuse in their
relationship but the partner
refuses to stop this
behavior, or the partner says
it will stop if the
partner does such and such?
WINIFRED REILLY: If you change.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
WINIFRED REILLY: OK.
Well, all right.
So if somebody is
screaming and yelling,
I differentiate this from,
you know, where there's, like,
physical violence.
So let's just take
that off of the table.
It's just kind of
bedlam at your house.
I think the surprising
thing is for you
to be able to remain calm.
I learned this from my
son's kindergarten teacher.
The room would be chaotic,
and she would lower her voice.
She would get really quiet,
and the energy in the room
would change.
Now, if your spouse
is off the rails,
you're not going to be able to
reason with him or her anyway.
And so I suggest you sit
down and be a witness.
Also you don't have to
argue every single point.
I mean, you know, you don't
have to argue if somebody
is saying the Earth is flat.
[LAUGHTER]
You don't actually have to
say, well, actually, here.
Here is why it's round.
You have to calm down.
You also might want to try with
a really nasty spouse saying,
you know, do you actually
think I can hear you
when you talk like that?
How about if we sit down.
Why don't you tell me what it
is you want me to understand,
or I don't really have any
idea why you get so frustrated.
Do you have any idea
why you totally lose it?
You know, that you
start to become
the ambassador for sanity
in a crazy situation.
At least, that's a start.
SPEAKER 1: Next
question, you talked
about standing on your
own and taking a position.
In the same vein, do you think
it's absolutely necessary
to spend time alone explicitly,
be single for many years
before being married?
WINIFRED REILLY: Well, I wasn't.
And you know, I was very
young when I got married.
And my sense of self, oh, I
sure thought I was an adult,
but I had lots of growing to do.
I think that coming in at
any phase in your life,
you're still going
to meet challenges.
That whole list of why is
marriage hard that I talked
about in the beginning, it's
still going to be difficult.
You know, you're going
to think, oh, I'm
a really sane,
well-adjusted person.
I can handle just
about anything.
And then, you know, you yourself
in a small space with somebody
and you're going to just see all
the little holes in yourself.
You know, there's this quote.
"A man can be a fool
and not know it,
but not if he's married."
You know.
SPEAKER 1: Very true.
WINIFRED REILLY: A
woman can be a fool
and not know it,
unless she's married.
And so I think that the
more solid and strong
we are as people,
the better it is.
But you're still going
to hit the trenches.
You're still going
to have to learn
how you live with this person
when agreeing to disagree
does not solve every problem.
SPEAKER 1: This next
question is great.
Any advice for
single people trying
to find or choose a
partner and wanting
to make that relationship work?
WINIFRED REILLY: Yeah.
Well, you know, it's the same as
anyone even in a relationship.
Be clear about what you want,
know as much about yourself,
and be willing to be brave.
Be willing to reveal yourself.
I have clients who come in
20, 30 years down the line,
and they've hidden so
many parts of themselves
that they feel strangled.
And you know, so the
thing when you're
looking for a relationship,
find somebody who's curious.
Find somebody who wants
to take an adventure,
but isn't going to be
a lark with anyone.
It's just not going to
be a walk in the park,
but somebody who is willing
to laugh, explore, grow.
It helps.
SPEAKER 1: And it's--
I appreciate what you said
just about knowing yourself.
WINIFRED REILLY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Because it
seems like no matter what,
how much you investigate
the person, or interview
the person, or try to
analyze the person.
WINIFRED REILLY: Right.
SPEAKER 1: It always
comes down to who
you are on the other side.
WINIFRED REILLY: Yes.
And that's true.
I mean, it really is--
you know, if you don't know
what you want, and who you are,
and what you think, if
you have no connection
to your inner most
reliable witness,
you're just going
to be moving about
and you're not
going to actually be
able to have your relationship
go in any direction.
And so, you know,
it's not for sissies,
is what say people say about
long-term relationships.
SPEAKER 1: Very true.
And this one, this
question, is about
long-distance relationships.
WINIFRED REILLY: OK.
SPEAKER 1: How
would one approach
this when a couple is in a
long-distance relationship?
And what are your
thoughts on each partner
seeing a separate therapist?
WINIFRED REILLY:
You know, so this
may sound like a kind
of a jokey answer,
but therapy can be one
of the worst things you
could do for your marriage.
I mean, there's
statistics about it.
So it doesn't mean don't do it.
It's just that you
will sometimes--
therapists will take sides.
You know, you've got two people.
If you're focusing, if you're
doing relationship work,
not just inner work.
Inner work is a different
thing when you're doing it
within individual therapy.
When you're doing
relationship work--
I've actually worked with
people where someone flies in
and I see them for, you know,
two or three hours, and maybe
a couple of times
in a short time.
And then they go back and
they do their own work.
But in a long-distance
relationship,
some of the pressure
is off, you know?
In the beginning I showed this
cartoon with the definition
of marriage is two
people in a rowboat,
and they're rolling in
opposite directions.
But that's some of
the stuff that happens
when you're living together.
Things heat up.
But you know, it's
the same, I suppose.
You know, any work, any
time that you're together,
pay attention to
yourself, what you want.
You know, don't shy away
from challenging things.
SPEAKER 1: When you mentioned
that therapy isn't necessarily
the best thing, it reminded me
of what you told us at lunch,
that you had a therapist that
recommended something that
wasn't--
WINIFRED REILLY: Yeah, yeah.
My therapist said, oh,
your husband, you know,
you're so frustrated.
He's really never going to
really take a hold and grow.
You really should, you
know, just move on,
which was stunning.
And I actually stopped that
therapy pretty quickly,
realizing that I would have much
rather somebody said, you know,
what I'm saying to people.
Well, this is
challenging, you know?
Fasten your seat belts.
Put on your work boots.
Get going.
See where you can go.
It wasn't that my husband
was immune to change,
he just was kind of more content
with things as they were.
So I came in with these ideas
for how to have it go better,
and you know, and
at this point, he
wouldn't argue that
our relationship is
much, much better because
we both basically grew up.
SPEAKER 1: And that leads
me to a question of,
how does one choose a therapist?
Because if you have a therapist
that is quick to say, yeah.
This isn't working out.
You guys should
just get divorced.
WINIFRED REILLY: I don't
think you should allow anyone
to tell you to get divorced.
SPEAKER 1: Mhm.
WINIFRED REILLY: Remember
what I said about marriage
being a choice.
You can stay with this
partner or you can leave.
But if you're going to
stay, you have two choices.
You can figure out what you're
going to do with yourself,
or you can allow that person
to drive you completely nuts.
And this business of figuring
out what to do with yourself
is really pretty extraordinary.
There are a lot of things.
You know, it's not
just we calm down.
But later in the
book, I have a thing
about what some people
discover to be change.
Like, one person
said his wife is just
a busy person moving around,
always drove him really crazy.
And then you realize,
it's a little bit
like living near train
tracks, but people eventually
stop hearing the train.
And he just stopped
focusing on it.
She was always running
around and doing stuff.
He figured out how to
regulate his own state
and be peaceful in the
midst of all of her people
coming and going.
You know, so rather than,
you need to slow down,
he figured out how
to just maintain
his own shape in the context.
SPEAKER 1: Next question.
How to agree or disagree
on parenting issues,
how we approach parenting,
if we are coming
from very different places.
WINIFRED REILLY:
This one, you know,
I could write an entire book.
This one is not a quick
answer because it's
one of those things that you
can't have two philosophies.
You can't say, we're never
going to spank the kids
and somebody is going
to spank the kids,
or you're never going to do time
out, or you're going to do--
you know?
And so I can't actually give
this one a quick answer,
but it actually
comes down to needing
to collaborate in some
way, but more to be
persuasive in terms of--
see, OK.
When you have two
things and you're only
going to have one
outcome, the only way
you're going to get
anywhere is that somebody
is going to have to yield.
Somebody is going to
have to be generous.
They're going to have
to say, all right.
This is not my first choice, but
from a solid and strong place,
we'll do what you want.
We can't compromise.
You can't have half a time out.
You can't have one
parent saying we
have no sugar in the
house and the other one,
you know, feeding the kid
sugar, or screen time.
I mean, these
issues, you have to--
it's sort of like this.
You're going to
either move over here,
or you're going to
move over there.
And how do you do it, I think
it requires a sense of self.
Don't expect these
conversations to happen quickly.
Hang in there with it.
See if you can both come from
the most curious and generous
places in yourself.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
And there are a
couple more here.
How amplified is the
"It Takes One to Tango"
message when one of the
partners can't change much?
For example, Asperger's.
WINIFRED REILLY: OK.
So I do work with
couples like that,
and so here's the piece that if
the Asperger's person actually
recognizes that there may be
ways that he or she isn't going
to change, but can acknowledge
that it drives their spouse
nuts, that's one thing.
And then for the other
spouse, to give up
all hope of this
person being different
and to make your own moves,
and think your own thoughts.
You know, I work
with one couple where
the guy would be-- he
would begin every answer,
or every piece of a conversation
was begun with the word no.
And he eventually stopped.
She'd say, I'd like
to go to the moon.
And he'd say, no.
I think, you know,
Pluto would be better.
But every-- no
was the beginning.
So she eventually got to,
I can just ignore that word
and I can listen.
And he actually did change.
I think people actually
can change, probably
not everything, but I don't
put a ceiling over what's
possible for people.
But I think, you know,
you pick this person.
You know somewhat of
what you're getting
and what you're not getting.
And you have to
figure out how to make
yourself happy in that context.
SPEAKER 1: Have you
ever seen the technique
you described work on a marriage
that has already failed,
where the partners are
divorced or separated?
At which point would you
recommend, as a professional
with experience, giving up?
WINIFRED REILLY: OK.
Well, if it's already failed
and you're already divorced,
I mean, I have seen
people remarry,
but I don't think that's
quite what you're asking.
So I'm going to answer
a question of, like,
how far gone is too far gone.
I actually-- you know, my
book opens with this quote.
It's a Turkish proverb
that says, "No matter
how far you have gone
down the wrong road,
you can turn around."
So I never give up.
It's not my job to tell
people, you know, you can do it
or you can't do it.
But I never give up.
I never put a ceiling over
what's possible for people.
But here's the thing.
Marriage is a choice.
If you want to try
and make it a go,
I say, you don't have
anything to lose.
Give it your all.
See what happens.
There's no guarantee as
to how it will come out.
But if you have even
one shred of hope,
start working on your side
of it and don't give up.
You still might
not end up married,
but I like people
to at least come out
of it being able
to say, you know,
I feel as if I really
did everything I could.
SPEAKER 1: This is
our last question.
You mentioned giving up the
idea about 50/50 fairness
and working as a team.
How do you then balance
day-to-day obligations,
such as parenting, working
without being completely run
down or bearing
most of the weight?
WINIFRED REILLY:
Well, you know, it's
tricky because this is a
common concern, especially
for the person who feels
like they're already
carrying more weight.
This idea is not
about how you should
be doing all of the cleaning,
and watching all the kids,
and turning cartwheels
about everything.
It really is about-- so if
you're in a situation where
your partner is not doing much.
This is a time where
you actually might
need to really step forward.
And instead of saying, you know,
like, what's wrong with you,
you might say--
this would be like what I would
say to somebody in my office--
so what do you tell
yourself while you're
sitting there reading
and your wife is running
around doing the dishes,
unloading the dishwasher,
and juggling three children.
Like, tell me how that
makes sense to you.
And so you want to find
yourself in a position
where you're not working
on changing your spouse,
but that doesn't mean, you know,
blooming where you planted.
This is why I say it's
going to take gumption.
You're going to have to move
toward your difficulties
and talk about them in
ways that figure out
ways to talk about them that
are effective, that aren't
about changing the other person
but are really about coming
forward and being yourself.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
Thank you so much for coming.
WINIFRED REILLY: Oh, It's
been really a pleasure.